hello Ross oh hello thank you for
hanging with me on 80 Canada Prime
course I'm thrilled few big news Drag
Race Canada is coming about I know I
cannot wait to see what Canada has to
offer the world of drag well Canada has
amazing drag queens so what is a good
tip for when applying for drag race what
grabs well you know we're looking for of
course the best drag out there you know
we're looking for the next drag
superstar
and so if whatever Queens are looking to
come on the show you have to ask
yourself how do you do drag what do you
contribute to the world of drag and then
you got to show it every week because
there are no tattoos there are no take
twos I mean the show I've been watching
since season one so I'm like a die-hard
but are you still surprised by the
amount of fandom that has come from the
show because every year it just seems to
be building more in there well you know
I've been a fan as well and I watched it
from my living room for the first few
seasons before I joined the show and so
I get why people are obsessed with it
because I think the show is just so
strong and has never lost its its way I
just think it is exactly it knows who it
is and what it is and what it wants to
say and I'm so glad to see that the
culture has caught up and not of course
just in the states but here in Canada
and then all over the world
I was just touring through Europe and
there were lines two thousand people
around the block because they loved the
show so much I was just so blown away by
what a worldwide sensation it is I think
the world was ready for it and something
that I love I mean you know it's not
just for the lgbtq+ community there are
so many money like best friends who are
female their boyfriends are like are we
coming over for drag race tonight well
it's unbelievable I was in an airport
the other day and this guy goes a
Bigfoot guy is like hey che kool aid was
wrong Sasha Belle or Sean say well this
is a question for you so I mean all the
Queen's are kind of your babies you all
watch them grow
it's is there somebody you just can't
let go of because for me it's somebody
like Chi Chi devayne yeah
and I mentioned that name to people
they're like oh she's not even on my
radar but I connected with Chi Chi
devayne
and I still connect with well that's the
beauty of the show is that because the
cat they cast such diverse Queens of all
colors shapes sizes types of queen I
think we all do relate to somebody for
example in the last season I loved all
the Queens but I related so much to Nina
last because she has this heart of gold
and she does so much for her community
and so you know I was just still
connected to her other Queens that I'm
connected to I mean I have I have my
favorite to make me laugh yeah but in
terms of like my heart I'm connected to
Vangie my thighs is out legs long I mean
there are so many ginger Minj of course
angel I'm so proud of shangela Alyssa
Edwards on the last guy there Kenny we
kept putting you can I go on well it
wouldn't be right if we didn't talk
about the Queen of the north I'm a
little biased because Brooklyn's a
friend of mine know I love Brooklyn I
love Brooklyn too and I have to say I
think I don't know people are gonna
probably yell at me for this yeah I
think Brooklyn should have one a lot of
people do I really do I think throughout
the season first of all I'm a person who
judges the Queen not only based on looks
but I like I like nice Queens hang I
like personalities that are you know
pretty people kept saying she need to
just step it up maybe a little louder I
didn't feel that way
I felt like she really proved herself
every single week on that runway that's
why she got as far as she did yeah you
at the end of the day you get to that
finale and it's a clean slate so listen
I love Evie as well and she makes a
great Queen I love Brooklyn yeah you
know I know it's hard it must be so hard
picking a winner
luckily rue does it easy oddly
you have so many people who look up to
you within the lgbtq+ community how does
it feel to kind of beat a representative
of that community and does it carry a
certain weight for you certainly it
feels great because I didn't have it
growing up there weren't people like me
on television and I remember being a kid
in a farm town and not knowing what AG a
grown up person looked like you know a
lot of the Queen's on our show now been
watching it since they were 10 20
they've been watching our show since
they were 10 I would have loved to have
grown up with people like me on
television because it would have skipped
the whole part where I didn't know if I
was okay or not you know and I just
could have started to be creative at a
younger age and not unless scared I love
that kids can do that now so is it a
responsibility yes but I wouldn't change
anything wouldn't change it is there a
message that you send to people who are
maybe watching this right now and are
unsure of themselves and their sexuality
and who they are what do you say to
those people don't rush it figure you
got time figure it out just do you write
you don't have it no and no matter what
you're good just own it
yeah yourself own it and love yourself
the other the other option hating
yourself takes too much energy you've
got stuff to do honey something to do it
go do it and if you can't love yourself
a man
[Laughter]